republicans are pushing back against
president biden's efforts to defend
abortion rights after the supreme
court's decision to overturn roe v wade
at a news conference overseas mr biden
called the court's ruling outrageous and
supported temporarily changing senate
filibuster rules to ensure the right to
an abortion scott mcfarland is at the
white house with more on the growing
political battle scott good morning to
you realistically what can the president
do at this point
hey gail at this moment on this issue
the president doesn't have many tools at
his disposal so he'll use the platform
the pulpit to try to rally some support
and maybe
rally some voters he has an early
afternoon meeting with seven governors
mostly from states led by democrats in
fact all of them states led by democrats
who've moved to protect abortion rights
the white house hoping to be seen having
the president seen next to state leaders
who are able to move on this issue and
the president
strongly urging congress to federally
codify abortion rights and to scrap the
senate filibuster if needed to do so
allows
this bill an abortion rights bill to
pass with 51 votes instead of 60 but the
problem is he doesn't have the votes
there are holdout
democratic senators who he has not been
able to budge and have said they will be
intransigent on the filibuster so he can
ask the senate to try to force this vote
try to change their minds and change
their votes but even if it loses
channel the anger of voters mobilize
them ahead of november
ed
that's right scott thank you he makes a
good point that this is his hands are
tied
we are in a system with three co-equal
branches of government he essentially
needs to convince congress to cooperate
and work with them but there's two
democrats who say i want to change the
filibuster for anything so president's
answer is elect more democrats so ed
have you ever seen when you strongly
urge congress to use god's phrase
is that effective no yeah yeah and the
former senator turned president knows
that but this is designed to get people
motivated going into november and give
people reason to vote for democrats and
we'll see if it works right now they
don't have the votes